听众朋友们大家好，欢迎大家收看新一期的一堂歌，我是Andy。
我是玉桐。
好的，我们这个播客已经做了一周年啦，然后呢，在这个时候呢，我们想要尝试一点有趣的新的形式，更加急性的更加有趣的形式，然后。
刚好最近不是高考嘛，所以呢，我们就决定来做一下高考题。大家可能多少有听说过一个事情，就是在法国呢，高考是要考哲学的。
他们的哲学高考题都出的非常有趣，所以我们觉得我们可以拿一些这个法国哲学的高考题过来，然后作为我们的这个聊天的主题来展开。
那当然，因为是做题嘛，所以呢，就不可能是像平时那样，我们预先就定好了这个题目是什么，然后我们有一些时间准备定一个提纲互相之间聊天，而就是非常急性的。
所以呢，这是一个类似于游戏的性质的节目啦。我们的这个制作人阿柴会帮我们选择一道题，我们不知道这道题是什么，然后呢，会在录制之前把这道题告诉我们，我们大概有15分钟左右的时间来准备，准备之后呢，就会开始答题了。
然后余同和阿柴都坚持要设立一个语言限制规则，我不知道为什么，我们有这个规则，这个规则呢，就是我们在这个节目当中不能说主义，也不能说什么什么信，不能说什么什么传统，就是不能说这种很专业的词汇。
所以我们虽然是在答哲学高考题，但是我们不能以这个很哲学的方式，不能以过分学院派的学术的方式去回答，然后要想办法用更轻松愉快的聊天的语言来做这样的回答。
虽然我觉得其实可能也没有办法做到很成功。如果我们要提哲学家的名字的话呢，每个人也只能提三个名字。
因为是对谈类的节目嘛，所以虽然是在答题，但是也不可能说一个人从头到尾答完，然后另外一个人再答，而是这也就在一定程度上考验我们跟对方对话的能力和随机应变的能力了。
我们要一点一点的在和对方的对话过程当中来展开我们的观点。那最后呢，我们也不会做打分账的事情了，
因为当然这个播客节目没有办法打分，如果听众朋友们想在评论区给我们打分可以打，但是我们没有办法打，
所以我们只能看一看谁违反规则比较多，更多提到了这种什么什么主意啊，或者多提了这个家的名字啊，
然后谁扣分扣得比较多呢，谁就是在这个高考当中就失败了，然后失败的人就会有一些惩罚，
这个惩罚呢就是自掏腰包来给我们听众朋友们送书啦。
这期节目如果大家在评论区给我们留言的话呢，应该就会有机会抽到我们送的一本书啦。
那大概就是这样了吧，然后这会是一个非常急性的聊天节目，我们也不知道结果会怎么样，
然后我们也都略微有些期待啦，那么现在我们就去抽题啦，大家待会见，拜拜。
我们抽到的问题是2015年的法国高考哲学做问题，我也不知道这个叫什么叫论述题吧，哲学题。
这道题，它原文是La Vente de Edet du Rue de Gondes，翻译过来可以是真理是否总是有说服力的，或者真相是否总是令人幸福的。
我已经可以想象，我不知道具体会发生什么，但是如果我是这个考生的话，我会想象我自己非常绝望的坐在考场里面，
然后再思考真理到底是什么。
因为我们在自己的生活中从来不会用真理这个词，它太大了，太红味了，
每当这个词被用出来之后总是会觉得你在骂人，对吧。
我们通常不会用真理这样一个词，然后这个问题真理是否总是有说服力的也是很困难的，
是因为我们怎么说呢，我觉得第一个问题可以讨论就是这两个词是不是能够非常密切的被放在一起。
我们可以说金钱是有很有说服力的，这个谎言是很有说服力的，
但是你会说一个三角形式很有说服力的吗，一个圆形式很有说服力的吗，
一加一等于二是否具有说服力，这些问题都是很难回答的，
因为你从来不会用是否有说服力这样一个表述去思考这种数学的真理。
那我先问你吧，Andy你对这个问题有什么样的回应的方式呢？
Right，你刚提到这个问题真的很有趣，就是我觉得至少我上高中的时候学到了这种达政治体的思路，
就是你要先回答是什么，你要先下定义对吧，然后下一步就回答为什么，
最后回答怎么办，就是三步走。然后就我所知在法国的哲学高考也是有非常多的八古文的格式的，
所以比如说我也能想象一个法国中学生坐在一个考场上的时候看到这个问题，
他的第一反应就是我要先试图解释真理是什么，或者给真理下一个定义。
这当然是非常困难的事情，然后我觉得我们至少首先我们不需要做这个事情，
因为一旦我们开始做这个事情，这个话题就无边无际收不回来了，
或许我们可以先从一个非常简单的日常职业出发，就是一通刚刚提到的，
我们从我们的日常经验当中也可以很明确的看到的事情就是，
哇，有些事情我们非常相信它就是真的，但是好像总有一些人没有办法被这个事情说服，
不管说我们在日常生活当中遇到的也好，还是在网上碰到的人也好，
比如说网上还真的有很多人相信地球不是个球而是平的，
还有很多这样的例子了，在我们看来再简单不过的事情，
甚至包括上数学这样的事情吧，因为一通刚刚提到了数学嘛，
我之前有看到很多人在抖音上面很生气的在评论区跟别人吵架，
关于运算到底要怎么进行，这个式子答案到底是多少，
然后会有明显算出来错误答案的人，非常坚定的认为自己是对的，
别人都很傻，怎么来这么简单的题都会算错，等等等等吧。
所以一个很直觉性的回答就是当然不是，真理并不是总是具有说服力的事情。
说到这里我就要问你一个问题了，你觉得地球是平的吗？
不是，为什么呢？我从中学开始在思考这个问题，
因为所有人都说地球是远的，但是我怎么知道呢？
对，这是个很好的问题了，我觉得这是个很好的问题，
然后这其实可以帮助我们去反思很多事情吧，对这个问题很简单的回答，
而且也是在我看来从很日常的角度去进行的回答，
就是我们都可以承认的一个事实是大部分人都相信地球是远的，
或者至少有地球这个词，然后我们在日常生活当中会用这个词，
就说明至少在汉语世界当中，它是求这个事情是一个大家所拥有的共识。
然后第二件事情就是这个大地，它是求体还是不是求体这个事情呢？
它是可以非常简单的去进行验证的。
我不知道你有没有学过这个验证方法？
就是这是一个关于这个太阳假角的验证方法吗？
就是如果大地是有弧度的话，那在某一天的某个特定的时间这个太阳照在一个地方，
它所形成的假角和你比如说照在靠南多少公里的同样精线的一个地方，
它所形成的假角跟如果大地是平的，它所形成的假角是会是不一样的对吧，
然后这也是古希大人去证明地球是远的的这样一种方式。
当然我要先说明，我没有做过这个实验对吧，
所以你问我是不是百分之百的确定地知道地球是远的我也不知道，
但是这是可以很简单去验证的事情。
但接下来就是说，如果我们假设地球大地真的是平的，
一个非常简单去验证的事情，你需要让几乎所有人都相信它是个球体，
这也就意味着这样的假设就要求做出这样假设的人在增设特别多的实体对吧，
你要增设一个比如说一个阴谋论的机构团体，
它在系统的运行着来阻止大家发现真相，或者阻止大家传播真相，
然后并且还有一个特定的目的，你还有解释为什么，
这么无关紧要的事情大家一定要压制真相等等等等吧，
所以这个从日常的逻辑来说，它就不是特别说的通对吧，
我们大家都很熟悉这个所谓的剃刀原则，
因为我们不能说说人的名字，
所以我们不能说什么剃刀，大家都很熟悉这个所谓剃刀原则，
就是如无必要物增实体，就是你做一个反执觉得假设之后，
要为了这个假设增加特别多很复杂的实体进来，
才能把这个事情解释得通，或许更好的解释就是，
不要做这个反执觉得假设，最开始大地是球体这个事情，就是真的，
然后我想说的这个事情就是，
其实我们在日常生活当中遇到的很多事情都是这样的，
就是我们确实没有办法百分之百的精确的，
必然的方式去验证这些事情，
而更多呢，这是我们自己从生活当中进行的一种解释学，
也就是我们获得了一个东西，
然后即使在我们的理性思考过程当中，
我们也不是遵循着非常严格的，
严密的科学的逻辑去验证它的真或者假的，
而相反我们在思考的是，
在我们所处有一个特定的历史和社会语境之下，
我们怎么样理解向我们呈现出来这个东西，
然后由此来推断主材大概是真的，
或者大概是假的。
我之所以问这个问题，
是因为我知道在理论上讲，
通过科学的同行评议我们确认地球是远的，
然后通过同行的方式我们也确认很多东西，
比如说空气是有多少的这种分子，
还有那种分子构成的，
或者这个植物的DNA它是和动物的DNA是不一样的，
植物细胞是有细胞B的，
而这个动物细胞是没有细胞B的。
这些都是真理，就是经过科学验证的真理，
但是我在看到这个问题的时候，
我首先会想到就是真理它在很多时候，
就是当作是科学真理来被理解的，
或者说一个真正的真理在我们现在谈到这个词的时候，
总是需要经过科学方法的验证，
但是我的感受完全不一样，
我的感受是真理是不能够让人幸福的，
是因为真理是无聊的，
真理是跟我没有关系的，
它是理论的，
然后站在一个旁观的角度，
一个匿名的角度，
去说这样或者那样的事情，
它跟我的生活没有关系，
之所以我也会相信地球是远的这个真理，
不是因为它经过科学的验证，
而是因为我的想象力就已经是这么被限定的，
无论是语言这个地球这个词，
让我这么想象还是这个地球，
从一开始在我小时候，
就已经让我想象，
把这个地球想象为是一个球体了，
然后让我去想象一个平的球体，
不是平的球体，
让我去想象一个平的地球是很困难的，
它是违背我想象力的法则的，
所以我会觉得它很有说服力，
但是所谓地球是远的这个命题很有说服力，
是因为它通过想象力抓住了我，
而不是真理本身抓住了我，
真理需要被想象出来，
如果没有办法被想象的话，
它对我来说就是没有效力的。
对，我觉得这个很好玩，
就是你刚刚在试图说的这个事情，
其实是与其说是真理有说服力，
不如说是你进行的想象有说服力，
人的想象是有说服力的，
然后从我的角度来看，
我听完这个故事之后，
我得出的结论是与其说真理有说服力，
不如说权力是有说服力的，
就是为什么你会有这样的想象，
因为你从小就被这样告知，
我当然没有说这是错的，
但是你被这样告知的原因，
确实就是因为某种知识权力的运行，
这个事情，
当它被作为科学事实确立下来了之后，
科学本身又在知识界当中，
占据一个比较强烈的主导地位，
所以在知识传承的机构，
比如在学校里面，
大地是一个球体这个事情，
就会因此被教授，
被反复的说，
被地球移的方式展现出来，
被各种各样的方式展现出来，
然后你从小就相信大地是球体，
你也不会去想这个事情，
不会去怀疑它是不是假的，
非常类似的事情就是，
我们当然都知道，
在中世纪的时候，
大部分的人相信大地是平的，
对吧,
就是因为就是教会的，
其实我不知道是不是教会，
就是教会的学术吗？
我也不知道，
我也不知道是不是教会的学术，
在今天的很多相信大地是平的人，
确实是，
处于宗教信念而去相信的，
当很多人相信大地是平的时候，
这也是由于一个特定的权力机构，
在维持着这样的信念，
然后你刚刚提到另外一个点，
是你觉得真理这个东西，
它很无聊，是吧，
它很多时候跟我们并没有什么关系，
其实我不是很确定这一点，
就是我经常觉得，
这些东西跟我们是很有关系的，
或者很多时候是跟我们，
是事关生死的一些事情，
我在网上，
在这个英语世界当中，
经常看到人们去进行辩论的一个题目，
就是有神论者跟无神论者，
跟无神论者之间的辩论，对吧，
结果有一些有宗教信仰的人，
他们相信神是存在的，
对于他们来说，这是他们的真理，
当然参与辩论的双方都不会允许我使用他们的真理，
这样的说法，
我觉得这是很成问题的，
他们觉得真理就是真理嘛，对吧，
但是对有宗教信仰来说，
神存在这件事情就是一种真理，
然后对于没有宗教信仰的人来说，
对于一个非常强烈的，
这种科学主义精神的无神论者来说，
你提到主义了，Kofan，
sorry，没有足够的证据表明，
神存在着，这就是他们的真理，
然后对于双方来说，
这并不是一个无关紧要的事情，
相反对于他们双方来说，
都是事关生死的事情，
我们想想一下这个事情，
就是你很可以理解对吧，
对于一个无神论者来说，
如果神真的是存在的话，
它就完蛋了，
这个教育就告诉他，
他会在地狱当中说到永恒的惩罚，
我想没有人愿意接受这样的结果的，
然后反过来对于有神论者来说，
那上帝对于他们来说，
是一个非常强的精神未解，
是一个很多时候能够坚持的支持他们走下去的事情，
比起他们有很多时候会提到的，
这样一种论证的路径，
就是说我之所以是个有道德的人，
就是因为我有一个宗教，
而这个宗教告诉了我什么是客观的道德，
如果现在我不再相信这个宗教的话，
我的整个的这种价值观，
我的道德观全部都会崩塌掉，
对于他们来说是非常非常重要，
非常非常时光生死的事情。
对，但是你提到这个辩论，
他所展开的这个领域，
在我们看来并不是和真理有关系的，
他们在辩论的一个是和自己的伦理的生活，
像密切关联的一个领域，
神不是作为一个理论真相存在着的，
至少对于其中一方来说了，
然后关于真理，
其实有一个还挺有意思的表达，
就是真理需要和有用性结合在一起，
只有有用的东西才是真的，
然后这个有用对我来说在有神论者的角度上，
可能就是说我有一个神的存在，
会让我觉得我的生活是有毛点的，
然后对于不信神的人来说，
没有这样一个神，
我的生活的自然完全是有可经验，
可把握，可计算东西来组成，
这个事实对他们的生活来说，
会提供一个稳定的毛点，
然后当我们去讨论这个的时候，
当你用这个例子的时候，
好像就我们就不再关心真到底是什么了，
或者我们更关心别的东西了，
我们关心如何去生活了，
然后我当然很同意就是，
这些比如说神是否存在，
或者这个地球是否是一个球体，
这些问题对我们来说，
也许确实是是关生死的，
可是他们并不是作为真理而是关生死，
他们是作为，我不知道生活的一方面，
就是我想提一个比较具体的例子，
就是最近有一个很火的宗义，
一个旅行宗义，
然后其中一个嘉宾还挺受到大家构病的，
我就不点名字了，我叫他A，
然后这个A呢，
他在这个宗义里面是有一个领队的这样一个职责，
然后他需要把大家在11点前带到某个公交车站那里去做公交车，
但是他迷路了，
他因为在国外导航系统不是特别的灵命，
所以他把大家都带偏了，
但带到11点10分都还没有到那个公交车站，
他们完全走了另外一条路，
然后这个时候所有的东西，
所有的人，还有一些规则还怎么样都告诉他，
这个点11点10分公交车已经肯定已经走了，
他不可能还在那等着你们，
那这时候这个宗义的其他嘉宾都决定要打车去那个目的地了，
就不做公交车了，
只有这个A他决定一定要去公交车站先看一眼，
确定他已经离开之后，
他才再次打车到那个目的地，
对他来说事关生死的是什么呢？
事关生死的并不是通过理论，
然后这个理论是指有人有一个当地的，
比如说像岛或者更加熟悉本地的规则的人，
或者就是这个公交车时刻表，
这些东西告诉他11点10分公交车已经离开，
这是真理，这是理论的真理，
对他来说他只是理论的真理，
但是他一定要去看一看，
我一直在思考这个事情，
就是我知道这个行为很多人购病的，
会觉得很偏执，
但是我还挺理解这个行动的，
是因为我觉得在身处同样的场合，
我可能也会有这样的倾向，
也许我会迫于其他的压力，没有这么做，
但是如果是我的话，
在一个人生地部所的地方，
我可能还是，
就是对我来说一定要看到公交车已经开走了，
才能够确定它开走，
这种怎么说呢，
感官的真理吗，和理性的真理，
在这里就是他们会打架的，
然后只有眼见为实的那个事情，
对我才是有用的，有意的，
能够直到我生活的东西，
所以对我来，我刚刚说，
真理总是个想象力有关系的，
但是这个想象力我说的不是，
凭空想象的东西，
而是你可以通过你的大脑，
或者你的心智，去想象到，
或者去赋予一个明确的形态，
这个形态当然也可以有感官来赋予，
你的眼睛来赋予，
然后一旦只有我非常明确的能够想象，
或者看到一个事情的时候，
我才能确定它是真的，
然后这种真理就跟我所说的那种匿名的，
没有关系的理论的真理是，
不一定任何时候都相互冲突，
但是他们运行是基于不同的逻辑来运行的。
OK，但是我想先问你一个问题，
就是如果是这样的话，
如果对你来说真理需要有某种直观的表现形式，
才能够说服你，
你会觉得像玻璃二相亲这种东西，
很难理解吗？
当然了，
我也很难理解三角形的内脚合适180度，
是因为我不知道我答这个东西来干嘛，
但是圆，
圆作为一个理论实体，
对我来说是就相当的说服力的，
因为我一定要想象出存在一个完美的圆，
而完美的圆是没有办法看到，
但是你可以通过想象去赋予它一个形式的。
OK，对，一通刚说这个事情很好玩，
然后如果我可以提醒一下，
我们的这个一开始题目的话，
我们的题目是真理是不是总是具有说服力的吗？
然后我们给出的这些回答，
看起来就是一边倒的否定性的，
就是当然这里跟说服力的事情没有什么关系，
但是我觉得也是，
其实有在整个整个史上有很多人意识到这一点之后，
大家就会想着说，
这可不行，
这个事情不太好，
就是我们吵起架来，
我总是没有办法说服对方，
对方没有办法说服我，
我们没有办法确定一个标准等等等等，
对吧,
所以,
试图为真理寻找一个能够具有说服力的标准这个事情，
是很多人都在试着去做的事情，
然后其中一个大家，
或者有些人尝试着去寻找的这样一个标准，
就是像郁彤刚刚说的一样，
就是以我们的感官，
或者以我们的知觉作为的标准，
对,
然后在现象学当中就有一个很有趣的概念，
叫做名见性，
英文叫做evidence，
其实evidence这个词，
在英文当中去这样使用的时候，
很多时候让人不知道他在说什么，
或者这个德语词evidence也不知道在说什么，
但是当你翻译成汉语，
然后有很多学者会选择使用名见性这个翻译的时候，
他听起来就很直观，
你一下就知道他在说什么，
他在说什么呢，就是你明明白白的看见了的东西，
然后,
这个在很大程度上，
就是某种现象学的真理概念，
就是他强调的是，
这个事情到底是什么样的，
我们先存而不论，不去讨论这个问题，
我们可以去讨论的问题，
或者我们在我们之间，
可以达成一致的一个问题，
就是我们到底看到了什么，
然后当这个东西只是被看到的时候，
他就是很有说服力的，
因为我们没有在试图说，
在这个被看到的东西之外还有什么别的东西，
而仅仅是在说这个被看到的东西而已，
如果比如说我看到你今天穿着一件红色的衣服，
有可能这个衣服其实不是红的，
有可能是这里有什么光线的错觉，
或者是某种信号传说的差异，
但这个无关紧要，
重要的事情是我看到它是红的，
这个事情不可能是假的，
因为我就是看到了我看到的东西，
这是一种去试图，
寻找一个真理标准的方式，
去试图，
寻找一个有说服力的，自明的整理的方式，
当然还有另外一个，
我们都很熟悉的试图，
寻找有说服力自明的整理的方式，
就是形式化的方式，
我们今天的科学是一个高度形式化的科学，
与同刚最开始提到的真理的例子，
就是一加一等于二，
这是一个典型的形式科学的例子，
人们试图去做这样的把科学形式化的工作，
很简单的原因，
就是因为在形式化了之后，
所有人都可以很好的去检验这个东西，
到底是不是符合那个一定要符合的形式，
如果符合的话，
它就是真的如果不符合，
它就是假的，对吧，
我们可以在一定程度上说，
这两种方式都是有效的，
他们都有效的，
确立了某种很有说服力的真理，
但是仅仅通过这两种方式，
好像还是不能够囊括我们在生活当中，
遇到的各种各样的问题，
各种各样的争论，
如果我们仅仅说，
我们感觉到了什么，
我们知觉到了什么，
或者如果我们仅仅是说，
纯粹形式的绝对逻辑的事情，
他们好像都不足以，
向我们展现出，
现实生活当中实在的复杂性。
我觉得这点说的特别好，
说的特别好是，
因为它点出了我们这个真理概念的一个很麻烦的地方，
是我们知道作为现代人，
我们总是会下一时的觉得，
现实是复杂的，事情是复杂的，
这个背后总是有一点什么，
这个复杂的没有办法被理解的机制在运作，
然后我在想的一个事情就是，
你刚刚提到那两个点，
一个是通过看的方式来获得确定性，
一个是通过醒示化的方式来获得确定性，
对我来说，
这两个办法其实都是沿着同一种道理去运作的，
他们都是沿着形式的道理去运作的，
行示化嘛，
然后还有眼睛所看到的东西也是个形式，
红色是一个形式，
我对这个词一直很感兴趣，
我觉得这里面有很多秘密，
然后形式是我们去把握事情的方式，
无论是把它做成一个套路，
做成一个模板，
一个逻辑的或者科学的一个形式流程，
还是说一个完整的可把握的形象，
一个球体，一个圆形，
一个三角形或者一个平面，
这样一些的，是可以被理解的，
然后反过来，
玻璃二象形就是一个没有办法被把握的，
它不是个形式，
因为我们没有办法想象这个事情，
然后我还想顺着这个去说一个词，
就是提到这看到，
当我们看到一个东西的时候，
我们就会自然的被说服，幸福，
你穿的衣服，
你今天穿的衣服确实是红色的，
因为我看到红色，
然后你知道哲学史上有，
其他人也是这么去理解真理的，
但是他们理解真理这个，
结论就跟你提到这个例子完全不一样，
柏拉图，
这是我这一次，
这是我这一期提到的一个人面，
柏拉图，
它的这个动学语是很有名的嘛，
这个动学语讲的也是真理这个词，
这个概念，
它的真理当然是被看到的，
但是这是一种怎样的被看到呢，
真理是太阳，
当你看到的时候，
你看到它的时候你就瞎了，
真理在这个意义上是强力的，
是有说服力的，
然后这个说服力在原题这里是。
convince,。
convince的词,。
你没有这个vinkle，
就是invincible,。
没有办法战胜的，
这样一个词干嘛，
convince总是,。
它征服你了，
真理征服你，
真理把你给说的啞口无言，
你在它面前感到无力，
你被占据了，
这样的带有征服，
还有占领的意味在里面，
然后我们很少去，
我觉得谈真理的这种说服性，
是对我来说是很困难，
是因为我不会在用柏拉图的这个方式。
去谈论真理的，
没有什么真理好像是仍然有那么强的，
当我看到它的时候，
它一下子把我决住了，
一下子把我所有的偏见都打破了，
把我所有过往的信念都打破了，
让我瞎了，
我觉得这个问题，
其实这个提法本身，
它看上去好像很成就，
但是它其实提出的是一个很古老的，
对于真理的想象，
就是真理不是一个亲和的东西，
不是像你今天穿的红色衣服一样，
你看到它你就自然的接受的东西，
真理在这样的情况下，
是具有暴力的，
具有说服力的，
但是这个说服力是以。
完全改变一个人的既有信念为结果的，
我觉得当我们讨论真理的时候，
我们也可以把这种看上去挺激烈的，
挺古老的，
跟我们现代人不太相容的这样一种真理观，
我真理概念给纳入进来。
我其实没有太理解，
你看到的这样一种古老的真理观，
跟我们当下的真理观区别是什么，
因为比如说从我角度上来看，
我会认为现象学当中的这样一种，
柏拉图主义的因素是非常非常明显的，
然后我觉得当然现象学家们也是在按照。
光的方式去理解真理，
这样一种穿透一个人的方式去理解真理，
包括遭我自己面对，
我认为能够带给我真理的作品的时候，
我的感觉也是，
就是他如此强力的说服了我，
我没有办法，
我现在没有想象事情不是这样的，
所以我感觉就是你刚刚提到的这样一种，
属于太阳的这样一种非常强的力量，
对我来说也是一个非常直观的去理解真的方式。
对，那我沿着这个问题，
我们原来的问题，
真相总是令人幸福的吗？
我想提出一个问题就是，
真相是否总是令人幸福的？
如果不能令人幸福，
那它就不是真相了。
如果它没有办法抓住你，
它没有办法完全改变你的生活，
改变你的视角，
那它只是一些命题而已，
一些可有可无的东西，
它不是真理，
它不能算是真理。
比如说，
一些不可呼吸的气体，
构成了这个空气的百分之七十，
我在小学听到这个命题的时候，
我大吃一惊，
原来我们空气当中，
可以供我呼吸的气体，
就那么那么少，
那是不是很快我们就要把它吸完了？
它对我造成很强烈的震动的，
但是玻璃二象性就没有办法，
可能也是因为我的世界观已经。
被原子这样一种形式。
给非常深刻的控制住了，
所以我妈想象一些。
不是原子的东西。
我觉得这很好玩，
其实我跟你想说的好点是，
在一个层面上同一方向的事情，
在另外一个层面上完全相反的事情，
你刚刚说的是真理一定是。
得是那些具有说服力的东西，
要不然他们就不算真理了，对吧？
然后其实我在准备的时候，
我想到的一个事情是相反的，
就是有一些东西，
它对于一些即使是非常非常聪明的人来说，
看起来也超级有说服力，
但是他们其实换一个语境之下，
就变得很可疑，
然后可能根本不是真理。
所以就是有的时候我们去寻找，
比如说我们找到像我们刚刚说到的，
像这样一种通过知觉去知觉到的东西，
或者通过形式化的方式去获得的这些东西，
然后我们觉得这些东西实在是。
太让人幸福了，
这些东西怎么可能是假的呢？
但是有可能你一旦换一个语境之下，
这些如此让人幸福的东西，
他们也可能是假的。
然后我自己让我产生这样一种。
强烈的历史相对主义，
主义的思想态度的事情，
就是这是我要提到的第一个哲学家的名字了，
就是迪卡尔在他的第一哲学陈斯基的。
一开篇提出的本体论证明。
我可以大概简述一下什么叫本体论证明吧，
这样大家就可以很好的理解这个事情。
因为本体论证明就是一句话嘛，
我们之前在节目当中也提到过，
本体论证明是一个去试图证明。
上帝存在的这样一个东西。
那当然我想说，
它有很多很多种不同的形式，
尤其是其实到今天也还在有逻辑学家们。
试图提出新的本体论证明。
但是在迪卡尔那个时代，
它的形式非常简单，
简化来讲，
就是它的形式基本就是这样的，
我们可以设想一个完满的观念，
然后这个完满的观念，
如果它只存在于观念的领域，
而没有现实的存在，
那它就不能叫做完满的，
所以一个完满的东西，
它一定是现实的，
所以有此推断出来，
肯定存在着一个完美的存在者，
然后这个完美存在者是什么呢？
我要给它一个名字的话，
它就会上帝。
所以这是一个基本上，
从思想当中，
凭空的把一个神给论证了出来的。
这样一种方式。
当然我们在今天觉得，
这显然是假的，
你怎么可能这样去论证任何事情，
对吧?
然后迪卡尔呢，
大家知道，
他是一个非常非常优秀的数学家，
他对于形式科学的理解，
应该是相当精神的，
然后对于什么东西，
符合这种形式，
逻辑什么的东西，
不符合，
也应该能够一眼看出来。
但迪卡尔是非常非常坚定的，
相信本体论证明了，
他甚至说，
这个证明对于他来说，
就像三角形那角，
和是180度一样不可怀疑，
这个证明对于他来说，
就一锤定音的，
证明了上帝的存在。
然后这个事情就让我意识到，
就是我们对于什么东西有说服力，
什么东西能够这样穿透我们，
对这样一种理解，
其实真的是非常非常相对的，
非常非常根据我们所处的历史环境的，
迪卡尔这样一个，
首先他相当的聪明，
其次他非常有学识，
再次他又在数学和逻辑这些领域，
受到过非常好的训练，
对这样一个人，
依然会相信，
一个在我们今天看来，
几乎不可能去相信的一个证明，
这就像我论证出，
就是我们，
怎么说呢，
就是我们的这样一种被穿透的，
被真理穿透的感觉，
或许也不是那么可信的。
对，提到迪卡尔这个例子，
我一直没有办法去切身的理解本体论证明，
通过一个性质，
一个完美的，
或者完善的，
完满的这个性质，
来推导出存在，
这种论证对我一直是不make sense的，
是因为他在逻辑上很强大，
但是我没有办法去想象他，
他没有形式，
他没有一个形状，
他也对我也没有什么影响，
但是迪卡尔他做一个强大的理性主义者，
他对我是有很深的影响的，
他讲到上帝这个东西嘛，
但是他同样讲到的是恶灵，
一个说谎的，
丑恶的，
一个恶魔，
在我读迪卡尔的时候给我造成了很深的影响，
我没有办法想象他说的上帝是什么，
因为这个上帝是通过逻辑推导出来的，
但是我很可以想象他提的这个恶灵是什么，
这个恶灵在我看来就是一个通体红色的，
有着这个蝙蝠的翅膀，
就是那些很很很沉旧的对于恶魔的想象了，
然后巨大，
他在看着地球，
然后用自己的各种手段来歪曲，
所有人内心的各种干的印象，
给他们造各种干的幻象和假象，
这对我来说是有很强大冲击力的，
这种冲击力的其中一个原因就是在于，
他是迪卡尔提出来的，
一个强烈的理性主义者，
强烈的形式主义者，
强烈的以逻辑为依据的一个哲学思想者，
迪卡尔之所以有这样的这样一个上帝概念，
我觉得完全不只是因为他在逻辑上，
像安色伦一样，
有形式证明上帝的存在性的方法，
相反因为他想象出一个恶魔，
他想象出一个巨大的恶灵，
然后他在生存上非常想要摆脱这个恶灵，
所以他才需要去借一个上帝，
他才需要设定一个上帝去做到这个事情，
迪卡尔相信上帝这个事，
在我看起来也不是完全不是相对的，
也是有一个我很可以理解的生存论的困境，
他的危机，他的不安组成的。
怎么说呢？我其实不是很能接受这种理解方式，
的原因就是我觉得当你这样说的时候，
迪卡尔会很生气的，
因为你的这个说法就是，
他在一定程度上并不是真的百分之百的相信他的本体论证明，
他有某种困境，他有某种苦恼，
他有某种情绪，有某种欲望，
然后他是出于这些可以说自然性的原因，
而去必须要设定一个上帝的存在，
迪卡尔肯定会偏近权力否定和反驳这样的事情，
并且说他之所以相信上帝存在，
就是因为这就是不言自明的真理，
我们作为外在的解释者，
很容易把相信真理的人所相信的东西给解释掉，
就是这两边的人在辩论对吧，
然后他们每个人都非常坚定的相信，
他们是出于某种为了真理的追求而做这个辩论的，
但是我们作为在外的人很容易去做这样的观察说，
你其实不是在追求真理了，
你有这样或者那样实用性的原因，
因为有这样或者那样生存性的原因考量，
所以你才在做这个，
然后你这边也不是，
你也是有这种生存性的原因的，
但是我觉得这样有点不尊重做这些分辨的人，
因为他们对于他们在追求真理这个原因，
就非常真心实意的很真诚在相信的。
对，那你怎么解释你的相对主义立场呢？
对，我的立场并不是大家都是被某种他们不了解的东西所驱动，
我的立场就是在不同的时代，
人们对于理性的理解是不一样的，
然后这种对于理性的理解是受到一个特定的时代的塑造的，
所以在这种意义上，
当迪卡尔再说有一个恶魔，
扰乱着我们所有人的视线的时候，
我们这个所谓的时代精神，
这个Cite Geist，这个Gaist，这个幽灵，
它就是我们每个人的恶魔，
它就是在扰乱着我们所有人视线的，
每个人的视线都被这个幽灵所扰乱。
在这种意义上，
迪卡尔他可能就是非常真诚的相信，
他就是从纯粹的概念当中推导出来上帝的实际存在，
那他就陷入了他的这个恶魔的魔掌当中，
然后在这个意义上我们今天的人，
可能有一些在我们今天的人看来，
在自明不过的真理了，
我们也可能只是陷入了我们自己的这个时代的恶魔的魔掌当中。
这样就不会显得不尽吗？
对，因为这样没有显得我比对方更加高明，
就是因为你的解释方式显得你能够看到对方身上那种自然性的存在，
然后你可以把他的真诚的意图给一种自然的方式给解释掉，
然后对吧，就是你把它误化了在这种意义上，
然后我觉得我的解释方式是在说，
我和他是一样的，
我们双方都是处在这样的一种困境当中的，
我们没有谁比谁更加高明一点。
Yes.
那一个相应的问题，
你觉得自然是令人幸福的吗？
恐惧是让人幸福的吗？
恐惧是一个能够很让人幸福的说法来解释这个人，
为什么做这个事情吗？
对，我觉得这是个很好的问题了，
就是你刚刚说的这个事情，
我觉得确实他就是有两面性的，
就是一方面我当然不能支持，
就是我不能接受这样一种解释别人的方式，
但同时另一方面我确实会赞同的事情，
就是在很多情况下，
人们当他们去讨论整理问题的时候，
他们所面对的不是一个纯粹理性的问题，
而恰恰相反是一个充满着各种各样情绪的问题，
一个人他相信什么，他觉得什么东西是真理，
确实在很多时候不仅仅是由他冷冰冰的理性。
做了非常明确的计算之后得出的结论，
而就是根据他需要某个东西，
他从情绪上面需要某个东西，
这样一种欲望会促使他更容易接受一些论据，
一些论证然后不那么容易接受另外一些论据，
另外一些论证，
然后我觉得这个也是为什么，
我们现实生活当中所面对的各种各样的情况当中所讨论的真理，
往往比我们前面所说的那些学术领域当中的，
比如说什么现象学的民建性，
比如说什么现代科学的形式化体系要更加复杂，
因为在我们现实生活当中所面对的这些问题，
并不是这种纯粹理性的冷冰冰的问题，
你要不然看起他的穿的衣服是红色，
要不然看起他穿的衣服不是红色，
是不是红色也不是很有所谓的一个事情。
而是我们现实生活当中，
很多我们在讨论的问题都是有切身的利益相关，
或者有跟我们的情绪紧密绑定的，
然后我们对其中的某个立场是有亲源性的，
然后跟其中另外一些立场可能没有同样的亲源性，对。
那真理是内在于还是外在于这个过程的？
这种亲源性人跟一些利益的关系，
里面有没有真理呢？
对，我觉得怎么说呢？
就是这个问题只能大家自己去回答这个问题，
我觉得就是每个人可能这是要自己去进行扣问的事情，
就是我真的我相信一个事情是真的，
在这个相信当中有多少是我异乡情愿的想要这个事情是真的，
然后有多少是我能够真的确信的知道这个事情是真的，
有多少是我没有办法区分出来到底是我的想要他人的，
还是我确信他真的等等等等。
我可以感受到我们对于真理的讨论是有一些现实的意义的，
因为这个世界上现在这个时代，
到处都是理念的分章，
一个很明确的理论之章就是进步和保守，
比如说美国在发生的事情，
一个如此撕裂的国家它发生了什么，
因为一部分人相信进步，相信平权，
然后在性别议题上走的更远，
另外一部分人在性别议题上走的更落后，
他们更关注传统的价值，更关注家庭，
然后这个家庭肯定是一夫一妻的，还有小孩。
在这样的理念之争背后有真理吗？
还是每个人就生活在不同的世界里面？
我不知道什么叫背后有真理，
但是我觉得这就是为什么我刚刚在说，
我觉得真理是跟每个人切身相关的，
或者生死相关的事情，
就是因为这些理念之争在每个人心中，
是由一定他们自己相信的真理所支撑，
或者所导出来的吧？
对，你提到每个人心中，
就是这是一种只有在内形，在内部才有真理，
一旦把它表述出来，
一旦想要把它拿到台面上去跟别人辩论，
这种辩论注定是没有结果的，
因为每个人的内在性都是只属于自己，
所以真理不是一个外在，不是一个公共的领域，
而是一个私人的领域。
而在私人领域里面真相总是令人幸福的，
我没有办法，
如果我是个传统的人，
我没有办法通过理念说服我自己放弃这些观念，
而如果我是个进步的人，
我也没有办法通过这个理念来说服我回归传统价值。
我觉得你说第一个事情是对的，
就是在很大程度上，
就是我之前好像在节目里面有提到过这个事情，
就是我觉得真理不是那么重要的真诚是更重要的事情，
然后真诚是什么呢？
真诚就是在每个人内心当中发生的事情，
危险的事情是相信有某种客观的真理，
而因此就觉得没有必要去考问自己真诚，
不真诚这个事情。
然后但是我觉得你说的第二个点，
就是真理在内心这个场面当中总是让人幸福的，
就是我其实不相信这个，
就是我意识到恰恰是在自己内心的场，
于动摇才是最有可能发生的事情。
我在跟别人讨论很多问题的时候，
我当然会尽可能的坚持我的原则，
这个事情就是这样的，
我绝对不会动摇对吧，
因为我一旦动摇了，
好像就违背了某种政治的或者伦理的原则，
然后我不愿意去做这样的事情，
我不愿意在这个政治的工坊当中跟放弃我的特定的阵线。
但是当在一个夜深沉静的时候，
我停下来，然后我自己去思考这个事情，
我在我的内心当中跟我自己辩论的过程当中，
我在多大程度上能够完全的相信幸福于某一套话语，
然后我能够在这套话语当中找到多少的缝隙，
来让其他人在这些缝隙当中说话，
我经常觉得是很可以的，
然后这也是我特别内耗的原因，
就是所有的我的信念我都会反复的这样反处思考，
然后我觉得就是这样一种在内心当中对自己进行的考问和询问，
或许是比公开的关于真理的辩论更重要的事情，
然后这个事情我之前录哈贝马斯那期的时候也有跟你提到过吗？
就是我知道有这个时政研究来讨论说辩论在多大程度上能够改变别人的观点，
无论是参与辩论的双方的观点还是听众的观点，
这个结论就是几乎不能对吧，
辩论在这种意义上是很没有意义的事情，
那有意义的事情是什么呢？有意义的事情其实是，
像不同的东西的敞开，
像更广阔的世界的敞开，
像文本的，像其他人的观点，以及等等等等这些东西的敞开，
如果一个人愿意敞开自身的话，
他更有可能去被改变，
相比愿意参与公共辩论的人吧。
我觉得刚刚说特别好，
就是关于这个夜深人静自我考问，
然后内心在白天坚守的信念在夜晚都会动摇，甚至崩塌，
就对我，在我看来啊，
这种情况他恰恰说明了真理的令人说服，令人幸福的特质，
因为很卑谬的事情是，根据这个说法，
好像当我们非常坚定的持守某个理念的时候，
这个理念它其实没有那么真的，
恰恰是在这个领域出现练习，
然后有一些其他的声音想要加入进来，
然后在这些不同声音发生争吵，
我的既有的信念的体系发生崩塌，
发生动摇的这个瞬间才是真理出现的那个瞬间，
也只有作为动摇，作为崩塌，还有缺失，
还有转变而出现的真理才是真正的真理。
这就是为什么柏拉圖他会用这种很强力的方式去描述真理，
他不是一个让你很舒服的事情，
他是一个让你彻底改变自己，
然后这个彻底改变自己不是就很无所谓的，
每天都发生的事情，他就是可能一生只会发生一次，
然后当他发生的时候你肯定知道他发生了，
因为你非常痛苦，非常动摇，你的眼睛好像要瞎了一样。
所以如果有什么结论的话，
这就可以说理念不是真理，真理是一些超过理念的东西，
超过一些命题，超过一些准则的东西，
然后当他出现的时候，所有的准则，命题，理念，信念都会只是显得令人幸福而已，
而只有那个作为破坏者的真相才是真正能够征服人的。
对，OK，我继续觉得这个观点很好，
这是一个很有趣的，我觉得它一方面表现出真这种东西，
并不是像我们的哲学当中总是意围的那样在某种完满性当中，
在于同说那个完美的圆形当中产生的东西，
而相反它恰恰相反是在断裂当中产生的东西，
然后这种断裂也就意味着它是一个不断发生的过程对吧，
一个东西断裂了，
所产生的东西可能继续断裂产生新的东西，
对，就行了，不知道为什么这个听起来像原子弹爆炸，
对，但是是这样的一个过程，Yes，
我们刚刚说了这么多，我们继续再说真理这个事情吧，
然后或许我们可以把这个词拉到更日常的领域当中，
而讨论所谓的真相这样的东西，
因为我觉得这是很重要的一个事情，
就是真理听起来非常的宏观高大抽象，
真相听起来就更日常更琐碎一点，
就比如说我可以去说我今天中午吃了什么东西，
这是真相，吃了米还是吃了面，
如果我吃了面，但是我骗你说我吃了米，
那我就没有说出真相，
如果我吃了面，然后我跟你说我吃了面，
我就说出了真相，对吧，
哲学家们讨论真理的时候总是会忘记，
它有一个非常日常的层面，
然后我希望我们在讨论当中可以不要忘记这个事情，
然后这个日常的层面我觉得挺好玩的，
从这个日常的角度上来说，
真相有没有说服力呢？
真相也跟说服力没有什么关系，对吧，
就是如果我跟你说我吃了米，
也没有什么证据能够证明我中午吃了米，
我只是跟你说你好像没有什么理由怀疑，
那如果这是假的，那它就是假的，
如果它是真的，它就是真的，对吧？
对，有这样一个词嘛，
在哲学界有这样一个词，
我特别讨厌这个词，
就是Trivally True,。
所遂的真，
对，说到这个，
我可以分享一个好玩的事情，
其实我觉得关于对这个词的讨论，
或许可以解释出某种有趣的事情，
你知道Trivial这个词的词源是什么吗？
不知道，
它其实很显然，一目表现，
它来自Tri，就是San，
以及V，就是Lu，
Trivia或者Trivia,。
就是三条路的路口，
上面在路口的时候，
人们遇到对方互相间交谈的东西，
就是Trivial Things,。
然后与此，
同样我们有Trivia这个词嘛，
就是所谓的知识境达，
或者有讲境猜，
然后在Trivia上面，
你猜这个东西也是，
大家在路口的时候会谈的，
这些有的没的事情，
然后这样一种，
所谓的琐碎的东西，
我们在路口的时候，
遇到我们去谈论的这些事情，
Well,
他们的真难道不重要吗？
我想提醒大家，
我们有的时候在街上碰面的时候，
事情是很重要的事情，
而有很多时候，
最重要的事情的真相，
真的就是通过这样一种在街头碰面的时候，
互相之间说一句而保存下来的，
我们大家都太熟悉这些事情了吧，
就是历史记录是可以被修改的，
历史序是可以被操纵和扭曲的，
但是在人与人之间的日常的交谈当中，
在人与人之间走过一条街道，
遇到的时候随意说的那一两句话，
或者会心的双目对视，
或者点一点头的这个过程当中，
有很多真的东西被传递下来，
被保存了下来，
然后我觉得这个事情其实是重要的，
这种真相是重要的。
你让我开始去思考，
什么东西在这种，
因为刚刚我在准备的时候，
也在试着分不同的真理，
比如说科学真理就是一个很显著的门类，
但是有什么伦理的真理吗？
比如说就像你提到的在路口碰到人，
然后大家都不说话，甚至不需要说话，
就点个头或者笑一笑，
这什么东西被承认了下来，对吧？
有什么东西，有什么真，
有什么不同于地球事源的这样的东西，
但是同样是真的东西发生了，
这个东西是什么呢？
我刚刚就在想，
比如说这个东西可以是我被承认了，
我作为你的朋友被承认了，
我的存在因为作为你的朋友，
而获得了一个不一样的面相，
一个很好的面相。
然后这是语言没有办法被表达出来，
因为语言充斥着谎言，
充斥着红变数，
有很多不真的不蠢脆的东西，
但是这种先于语言的点头还有微笑，
它恰恰是能够表现出一些真，
它甚至都不是理论的了，
因为它连语言都不是。
对，这个还挺好玩的，
就是有一个很好玩的例子了。
我想这次会提到第二个这个家名字了，
就是二都赛。
陆一二都赛有一个很有趣的词，
或者概念我不知道语统知不知道，
就是interpolation。
二都赛用这个词来表示打招呼的意思，
同时它也暗示这个词当中内涵这一种让人臣服的意思。
他说一个人如果跟一个人打招呼的话，
在一定程度上，
这就双方之间就已经产生了一种权力关系了，
打招呼的人在让那个被打招呼的人臣服，
这是个让人觉得非常奇怪的观点，
对吧?
为什么会这样想？
但是其实有这样一个例子，
就是这个例子是我在世界哲学大会上，
听 Judith Butler讲的这个小故事，
就是她说她在外面这个旅行的时候，
人们见到她经常叫错她的性别，
我们大家知道 Butler是一个女性吗？
对吧?
但是她的这个半项打扮，
她的头发很短，
然后她的这个面部线条也比较硬朗，
所以很容易让人误以为她是男性，
就很多人叫她mister，
叫完她mister之后就会跟她道歉，
因为意识到她其实是个女性就会跟她道歉。
所以我们就意识到，
即使在日常生活当中，
在一个人遇到另外一个人，
然后我们要打一个招呼，
我要称呼你。
在这个过程当中，
我就已经把你放置在某种性别秩序之下了，
我要给你定个性，
你要么是男的，
要么是女的，
然后我要由此给你加一个前卷，
mister或者missus。
当人们没有办法去完成这个定性的时候，
人们就会感到困惑和痛苦。
从这个角度上，
我们可以去理解二度赛的这样一种，
打招呼已经是一种让人臣服的过程。
但是,
你从刚刚提到这种点头啊，
这种握手啊，
这种微笑啊，
这种前缘的活动，
或许,
在这种意义上就跟二度在所说，
这个interpolation不太一样，
它不涉及到臣服，
它不涉及到归类，
它只是单纯的去向你表达一个质疑。
我还挺喜欢这个例子的，
就是打招呼，
interpolation,。
它的字面意识就是介入的意思啊，
但这都无关情要。
比如说，
这有一种比较特殊的种族主义的形式，
就是走在国外街上，
然后有人跟你说你好。
这对我来说是极具冒犯性的，
对很多人来说也是这样。
是因为，
像是他已经用性别的贩手。
把你接定好了一样，
他用这个语言的方式。
来把你接定好了。
他把你明确的说，
明确的接定为是个中国人。
这是一种权利，
因为这是一种主观的，
他单方面的就给你下定义的，
这样一种行为嘛。
但是我还在想的就是，
打招呼这个事情也许，
根据不同的语种，
根据不同的语言，
根据不同的打招呼的习惯，
这个打招呼当中体现出来的权利关系，
或许会有不一样的表现。
比如说，
我觉得你好，
还有比如说 good day，
或者 good day,。
这些东西，
这些表达，
都是稍微大有点权利的意味。
我觉得这个不是特别准确的用法，
但是,
他之所以会有点向权利，
是因为他是一种 benediction，
一种宣服，
是一种我希望你，
我决定你，
或者我表达了这个心愿，
说你要过一个好日子。
但是,
像是比如说，
南德在奥地利，
大家会说 service，
这是一个很，
他不是一种宣服，
他是一种臣服，
他是自己表现出了的臣服。
service 就是我是个仆人的意思，
我为你服务，
这些都无关红旨了，
但是,
打招呼小词这里，
就可以看到很多很有趣的权利的关系。
然后,
对我借着打招呼这个词，
我想回到我们原来的问题，
真相是否总是令人幸福的？
这个例子就很好，
想念出，
当出现真相的时候，
它总是令人幸福的。
这个真相甚至都不需要是语言，
不需要命题，
它只需要打个招呼，
然后你一下就，
被说服了，
一下子就被确认了，
你们之间的关系，
这个关系是无用质疑的，
它不需要更多的确认。
对，然后，
与之相关的，
我也想去聊一下，
比如打完招呼之后，
如果我们要聊两句的话，
在这聊两句当中，
所产生出来的，
或者是显现出来的真相，
这种所谓的，
流言非语也好，
咸言岁语也好，
茶语饭后谭字也好，
似乎是，
在至少在哲学等级当中，
最不真的东西了，
没有什么东西，
比这个更不真，
你如果要讨论真是什么，
然后居然塑出到这种层面的东西的话，
大家都会很鄙视你，对吧？
但是,
我觉得很有趣的恰恰是，
Well,
人们其实最没有必要，
去欺骗别人的时候，
就是这种时候，
就是在我走在街上，
很无意见遇到你，
然后我要跟你随便说两句话，
首先,
我没有动机骗你，
其次,
事情是，
我需要说谎话，
我大可以不必在这个时候提，对吧？
我提点别的东西就好了，
我想说的是，
这个就是在日常的这种交流过程当中，
是有很多真相显现出来的，
然后我们很多时候会不相信，
这种我们所谓的这种，
无论是身边统计学也好，
还是对于附近的观察也好，
很多人会倾向于否定他，
不相信他，
因为他不具有真的含义，
不具有科学价值，等等等等，
但是,
这里其实有很多真的东西的，
然后一个，
给我印象非常深刻的事情，
并且因此，
在我的这个，
很多关于文学理论的笔记当中，
都出现的事情，
就是,
你和我们的插画师阿柴，
有一次跟我聊天的时候，
我不记得是谁跟我说的事情了，
有一次，
你们当中的某一个人，
跟我提到广州刮龙卷风的事情，
你记得吗？
我不记得了，
Right,
有一次，
你们跟我提到广州刮龙卷风，
然后呢，
你们跟我说火在天上飘，
然后,
我当时，
我当时的第一反应就是，
火怎么可能在天上飘呢，对吧？
这肯定是假的，
但是,
我就立刻意识到，
你们肯定没有在说假话，
就是,
火在天上飘这个事情，
如此的看起来不可思议，
首先,
没有人会，
设想一个火在天上飘的情景，
其次,
就算你把它这样想出来了，
你也没有必要在这个时候，
用这个事情来骗我，
当你忽然间说了这样一句话的时候，
虽然我不知道到底，
广州刮龙卷风的时候发生了什么，
但是我知道，
在这个火在天上飘，
这句话背后肯定运藏着，
某种真的东西，
即使它可能并不是真的，
就是完全字面以上的有火飘在天上，
对，这就是我后面在去，
思考很多文学理论的时候，
我的一个着手点，
就是这句，
火在天上飘，
就是在很多文学当中，
我们会遇到这样的，
的笔记也好，
故事也好，
这些笔记和故事当中记载着，
首先,
很多他们的这个作者，
到底是谁已经不详了，
其次他们当中记载着，
很多很多非常荒诞的事情，
不可思议的事情，
然后,
第一眼看过去，
你的第一反应，
当然就是这是假的，
对吧,
不可能发生这样的事情，
比如说，
我不记得哪个，
什么奇怪的笔记当中记载说，
应该就是在北京，
某一次发生了一个大爆炸，
把人的衣服都炸没了，
就是人好好，
但是衣服都被炸没了，
对,
就是你就觉得，
这显然是假的吗，
怎么可能有这种事情发生呢，对吧，
但是有的时候，
当这种非常非常荒诞的事情，
出现的时候，
它反而，
向你表现出，
向你招式出，
背后可能有某种真的东西，
运藏在那里，
就是因为像我刚刚说的，
没有人会，
专门写一个如此荒诞，
不经过我们起码的谎言，
放在这里一眼就能看专人，
然后,
要来告诉你，
肯定有某种东西发生，
某些事情发生了，
导致了这样一个结果。
我觉得，
这也是我很多时候，
因为,
我们在聊，
本亚民的，
文学理论那一期，
有聊到虚构者观念吗，
与之相对的一个，
文学当中的观念在我看来，
就是故事，
然后故事它不是虚构的原因，
就是因为，
它不是非常明确的，
有一个人，
去写出来的，
去造作出来的，
故事可能是最开始发生了一个什么东西，
然后有一个人去讲，
下一个人，
听了他讲之后，
再去跟别人讲，
这过程当中，
形成的一个事情。
像故事这种东西，
它在这种自然的生长过程当中，
发展出来的，
或者,
也有可能，
它从一开始就有的，
很多很多荒诞的面相，
很多很多看起来是假的面相，
其实恰恰是，
我觉得一些被隐藏，
被掩埋着的历史，
在试图向我们宣告，
某种真相，
这种故事，
这种口耳相传的故事，
这种,
最后,
流落到某片不知名的，
笔记当中的故事，
其实就是我们刚刚说的，
这种吹牛的故事，
就是,
人们会在街头，
互相抱遇的时候，
聊起来的莫名其妙的故事，
像活在天上飘润的事情。